in today's ad on your side rent price is
dropping Nationwide for the first time
this year according to a new report from
leading National resource rent we take a
look at where prices are dropping the
most in southern Nevada and what kind of
negotiations might be possible with your
landlord
our record home prices across Southern
Nevada the past two years priced out
home buyers and drove up rental prices
the rental market tends to follow the
housing market now that our housing
market has cooled what can we expect for
rent the good news is that the increases
have
lessened their Pace but the bad news is
that it seems like those higher prices
are kind of here to stay here are the
top 10 cities with the biggest increases
in two bedroom rent prices year over
year Fremont California Salt Lake City
Utah and Seattle making that list
for the cities with the biggest
decreases in two bedroom rent prices
North Las Vegas comes in ninth Reno also
making the list as did Irvine California
North Las Vegas was actually an area
that saw some decreases in two bedroom
apartments and uh Las Vegas proper also
saw some slight decreases considering
it's still a landlord's Market lead
researcher John Leckie of rent.com says
if you're happy where you're at think
about staying landlords are going to be
much more willing to work with someone
they know has been a good tenant if your
lease is coming up do some research see
what Brent has been historically in your
area and what the increases have been
year to year if you've done your
research maybe you can get your landlord
to sort of uh get those increases more
in line with what you've seen
historically rather than what we've seen
over these last few years
he adds you can also ask your landlord
for a concession consider signing a
longer lease term and if you don't need
it offer to give up a designated parking
space to potentially get a credit or
discount on your rent